quick one the dire ceo live my live show
my live reincarnation of this podcast is
coming on tour and it's coming to a city
near you there's a link in the
description below put your email address
in and i will email you when tickets go
on sale
can't wait to see
[Music]
i get so many questions from all of you
guys in my dms in the comment section on
youtube everywhere so i want to try
something new i'm going to start
answering some of those questions that
i've historically answered privately in
public so more of you can gain access to
those answers i asked everybody in my
telegram community to submit videos of
questions that they want answered from
me and in this video today i'm going to
answer those questions with total
total honesty and these questions range
across business to personal questions to
questions about relationships and mental
health and challenges that you're facing
so here
is the first question you asked me this
week
my name is daniela i'm 18 and i'm about
to enter my first year you need to study
economics i have a lot of commitments
i'm running a business my business
partner i'm making music i'm learning
languages and i'm playing sports and i
worry that my focus is split
how do you suggest i move forward do you
think i should grip my teeth and balance
everything to the best of my ability or
do you think i should prioritize and
sacrifice for better quality output
despite loving every single thing i'm
looking forward to your response thank
you so much for listening
i think the single biggest lesson that i
learned when i was starting off early in
my business career was the importance of
focus and i had this drummed into me by
one of my investors one day when i came
to them and presented this new idea
which was an addition to the current
company that i was building and they hit
me really hard with this like verbal
whip and told me they said steve focus
is everything and that stayed with me i
was annoyed at the time because
naturally when you're a creative person
and a very inspired person as many of us
are you have so many ideas and the
problem is you can't take on all of
those ideas at once and any attempt to
do so compromises each individual idea
so if you have three ideas and you're
giving them 33 of your time each the
chance of mastery or success in any of
those things is drastically drastically
reduced and especially when it comes to
business if you're giving anything less
than 100 of your focus to your business
you you can rest assured that there are
very competent probably better funded
competitors out there that are giving
100
focus and your time is the only currency
that you have so making the decision to
invest only a part of your time and
focus into what you're doing is a
decision
to reduce the chance of a really
successful outcome and here's another
thing so i don't know how
solid this is as advice but honestly
when you're young and you're broke and
you're bootstrapping focus matters even
more so for me
what i would do and when i think about
the 50 years of my career is at the very
very start i'd go very very very narrow
and i'd try and succeed in something
that'll be the gateway if it is
successful to me being able to build my
resources my financial resources my team
so that i can focus on multiple things
and that's really the trajectory i've
taken in my life i at 18 years old
focused on one thing one business idea
and really nothing else and when i say
nothing else i also mean a lot of
personal things were sacrificed i
focused on that for the for about seven
years in total that business became a
success i now have resources to allocate
against multiple
things that i want to do which frees up
more time so i can start companies now
and not even be the ceo of these
businesses but when you're when you're
starting out in life in your career
that's not a luxury you have so my
advice for young people would be to do
everything in your power to focus in
business what we do is we operate in
sprints which means when you have an
idea you assemble a team around it and
you focus them for a dedicated and
predetermined period of time say three
months or six months only on that idea
to give it its best possible chance of
success and after those six months you
assess it and you make very brutal very
honest very ego-free decisions whether
to continue or not that's how i like to
think about focus and projects and how
to make the decisions around allocating
your time what you really should do if
you want to give an idea its best
possible chance of success
if you want to give djing your best
possible chance of successful writing
that book or becoming a content creator
is you should look at the task and
dedicate the next six months to doing
that and only that if you allocate time
to other things in that period you're
reducing the chance of a positive
outcome for that one thing and i i tend
to see as well especially young
entrepreneurs when they have multiple
businesses and multiple things they're
pursuing in multiple things they're
trying to master at the same time as the
phrase goes they become the master of
none which means they kind of stumble
through life never really achieving any
real substantive success because they've
spent all of their life trying things in
a half-assed timid way if you want to be
successful if you want to get mastery in
anything that matters to you here's
where discipline really really matters
you have to install into your mind
something i call the sunday shelf which
is
inspiration comes to you you have a new
idea when you're walking down the street
or in the shower you think that's
brilliant that will be a multi-gazillion
dollar idea we all do it if you want to
be successful don't then add it into
your successful idea don't then try and
contend with two different ideas and
give 50 to each put it on the sunday
shelf and see if it nags you the great
ideas will sit there on that someday
shelf and they will nag you and if it
nags you for long enough
six months for a year then maybe it's
time to take action but my mind has a
someday shelf on it that has hundreds
and hundreds of hundreds of things on it
and if something sits there for more
than a year more than six months and
it's still screaming at me and it
doesn't dissolve away and
collect dust on the sunday shelf and
disappear into the back then i pull it
forward and i put a plan in place to
give it the sprint it deserves to
resource that idea and give it its best
possible chance of success
hiya stephen my name's chloe and my
question to you is what do you believe
to be the most important character trait
that a person has to possess in order to
achieve a hugely successful business
i would love to know
in terms of character traits to build
really successful businesses i kind of
think of it in stages and i think of it
in stages of the business's life the
question here is about the character
traits it's not about skills or talent
or resources it's about character so at
the very start of launching your company
the most important character trait is
self-belief is believing that you can
because businesses they feel like mount
everest at your doorstep and they look
like incredibly daunting tasks that you
typically
don't have a ton of experience in
overcoming right you don't you've never
climbed to mount everest before you
don't have the resources you don't know
how to get up there you don't have the
experience to rely on so there has to be
somewhat
an extreme level of delusion
self-belief to even want to start doing
something you've never done before and
then when it comes to creating really
innovative things you're bringing
something into the world that even the
world hasn't seen
so that's where having a belief that
this thing can exist and having that
self-belief is also incredibly important
this is just kind of the inception point
of the business and when you go out into
the world and you start telling people
about your amazing business idea and how
successful you think you're going to be
and that you're going to be able to
change the world in some type of way or
solve a problem in a new way you're
going to get tons of
positive
feedback from your friends maybe but
also a ton of resistance whenever one of
my friends starts a company
and they ask me for one piece of advice
i always say the same thing i say
there's gonna become a day in your
company where things are just
awful where it's so
unbelievably painful i've never seen it
not happen so i can say would say it
with such a high degree of conviction
that it is going to happen to you
so let's not argue about you know how we
stop it happening because it will find
you at some point let's start thinking
now about what it takes to overcome that
day it requires a ton of resilience it
requires a ton of self-belief um it
requires a certain temperament where
someone defaults to logic and reason and
not emotion because when emotion arrives
in on that day then your decision-making
will go down and you'll make really bad
poor decisions that often exacerbate the
problem but the first encounter of the
35 packages of [ __ ] will build
evidence that you can overcome and i
think that will compound in your favor
over time i think self-belief and
resilience are probably the number one
and number two character traits of
anybody that wants to be wildly
successful in business and then quite
honestly
everything else is outside of character
traits i mean of course it matters to be
really really nice of course it does
that's that's a
a factor that will increase your
probability of success of course it
matters to be you know have a great
sense of humor but i think those two are
at the very core of what it takes to be
successful especially when you're a
startup and then everything beyond that
is quite often luck it's quite often
outside of your control especially in
industries like technology and when
you're building products because the
question then becomes okay i was
resilient i had belief but does the
market care and is their product market
fit do people want to use my website my
social network my app do they want to
use my product that i've invented and
that's somewhat outside of your
control however what is in your control
in that phase let's call this phase two
of business
is your humility and ego which will
often show up
stubbornly trying to prove that you were
right and entrepreneurs like me
in the past have been too romantic about
our initial hypothesis about how we
thought our product was going to be used
how many people would we would use it
the problem it would solve and you look
at your product and you see clearly in
the data that people are using in a
different way they want a different
thing
that is outside of your original thesis
your original hypothesis and some people
at that moment they'll stubbornly try
and push their original idea their
hypothesis into existence let's increase
the marketing let's educate the user
base but really
if you're humble enough and you're not
attached to your ego you're attached to
the outcome and success of the business
you'll say let's pivot
let's change what we thought was true
to fit what we now know is true and
that's where i think humility and and
a little bit of experience because i
think
experience generates humility comes from
you know when i sit here on the podcast
i speak to people like
tom from monzo and other founders of
these massive companies that have
disrupted industries one of the things
they consistently say to me is
i now know it was 10 times harder than i
thought and we were like 10 times
wrong in our initial hypothesis about
how this business would play out than i
originally realized throughout all of
this as i've said multiple times in my
podcast from day one to the day that you
exit the business for a 500 billion
dollars sales is everything sales is
every single touch point and also
especially as your business gets bigger
and bigger and bigger it's incredibly
important to be self-aware because
there's going to be a million things
that you're actually not that good at
that need to be done within your
business there's going to be a million
things whether it's finances or you know
typing into excel sheets or it's
creative or it's whatever and so many
entrepreneurs i know especially young
inexperienced entrepreneurs that i know
fail late in the day their business
explodes at first and then plateaus and
then declines because they didn't
realize that they needed to put in place
another ceo
because for them the ego here of
replacing themselves and giving someone
that very prestigious very lauded title
wasn't worth it i can also think of the
opposite i can think of companies like
jim shark like huell like tarla grace
beverly's business where those founders
have said you know what
there's someone better to run the
company it's super successful i'm going
to get out of its way and i'm going to
spend all of my time doing something
else that i'm uniquely positioned to do
this is an incredible incredibly
important skill and even in the
companies that i found now i say to
myself am i really capable of being the
ceo is that really where i should be
playing and in the two businesses that i
founded since leaving social chain i am
not the ceo because that is not what i'm
best at and i'm more attached to the
outcome
and the success of that business than i
am of having that title which might get
some brownie points from people that
don't really matter anyway
you know i hate i hate
powder i hate mixing powder with water i
hate protein powders that you have to
mix with water
up until now and um obviously he'll
sponsor this podcast so i'm tremendously
biased but that's a that's a true story
i've never been able to use the like my
protein powders that you mix with water
because i always think they taste
absolutely awful
up until hull released their brand new
protein flavor the amazing thing about
all of these proteins is there's 20
grams of protein you get all of your
vitamins and nutrients 26 of those and
as huel always is it's nutritionally
complete
and if you are someone that's trying to
go a little bit lower on the calories
it's only 105 calories so when i wake up
in the morning especially i've been
working out a lot lately come downstairs
quickly blend it together in my
nutribullet
drink it's 100 calories and then my next
sort of main meal because i'm a
breakfast skipper will be
at lunch time highly recommend it um and
i shouldn't say this because i don't
have any approval to say this but
there's some amazing amazing flavors
coming in the ready to drink range that
i've been lucky enough to try um
and
one of those is my new favorite flavour
so stay tuned
hey steven hop all as well so my
question is with regards imposter
syndrome have you any feedback regards
how to deal with that have you
experienced it yourself and just how to
go about like getting out of that
mindset and acknowledging that you
are potentially as good at your role as
what people think you are and you're not
bluffing it or fluking it and so on
thank you
so here's the thing i think we all feel
deep within us the same feeling any time
we're in a position that feels a little
bit outside of our comfort zone
sometimes that feels like a little bit
of nerves in your chest for example when
i go up on stage and i know there's 10
000 people behind the curtain of course
i feel that in my chest of course i have
that tingling that sensation that they
call butterflies however i don't
interpret it as being fear as being a
signal to escape or to avoid the
scenario my interpretation which has
grown over time and our interpretations
are influenced by our beliefs the
stories we tell ourselves based on the
evidence we have based on our
experiences and my evidence my
interpretation tells me that i'm ready
that this feeling is normal and i'm
supposed to feel this way people
sometimes because of their experiences
and the evidence that's created and the
stories that's made them believe about
themselves will tell themselves that
that feeling is fear that they should
run that they are ill-prepared that that
feeling is there because they aren't
competent enough to complete this task
so what i'm saying is we all get the
feeling but the story we tell ourselves
is ultimately what creates what some
people call imposter syndrome for me if
you look at my life i've kept myself one
step outside of my zone of comfort for
my entire life of course i've never been
a dragon on dragon's den no one in their
first year has been i'm looking to my
left and seeing peter jones who's been
there for 17 odd years and deborah meade
and to my right who's been there for 15.
i am new
however i'm supposed to spend my life in
situations where i am an imposter that
is the sign of growth if i'm ever
spending
too long in a room or situation where i
don't feel to some degree like an
imposter i am in the wrong room and if i
am to grow and growth is an incredibly
important part of being stimulated and
motivated and being fulfilled i have to
change rooms for me in my life i've
spent my entire life trying to escape my
zone of comfort and keeping myself one
foot outside of that zone of comfort
when you do that what you find is that
zone of comfort expands you take one
more step and it expands again every
person that's ever done anything for the
first time whether it's ed sheeran
singing to a group of people before or
barack obama doing one of his speeches
or usain bolt running in a track when
they first started they were
inexperienced and incapable so you
should expect and welcome that feeling
it's a feeling you're supposed to have
if you're somebody who wants to spend
your entire life growing and progressing
and learning which are all things
conducive with fulfillment you should
always feel like an imposter if you're
not i would assert that maybe
maybe you're playing it too safe maybe
you aren't challenging yourself enough
so for me what people call imposter
syndrome isn't evidence that you're in
the wrong situation one that you aren't
supposed to be in it's clear proof that
you're in the right one you're exactly
where you're supposed to be i'm i'm
supposed to spend my entire life doing
things that make me feel somewhat like
an imposter that is the answer to a
happy fulfilling progress full life
where i'm striving forward i'm trying
things i'm challenging myself and i'm
pursuing goals that are worthwhile we
should all feel impostor syndrome so if
you're not then it's time to challenge
yourself more
hi steve
my question to you is starting off in an
industry in my case healthcare and
medicine how do you approach someone at
more senior level and at level that you
want to be at
to ask them for mentorship or to be able
to help you along the journey that
they've been on
is there anything that you could say do
or offer them that would make them more
inclined in taking you on board
thank you so much the answers to these
these complex especially professional
questions as it relates to asking people
and progressing are always so simple yet
we complicate them and that would be my
answer genuinely it would be the person
you're speaking to put yourself in their
shoes how busy are they what are their
interests what do they want what could
you say to them to make them give you
something very precious to them which is
their time and like if you can't answer
that question
i i you know oh it makes me slightly
concerned because that's an inability to
put yourselves in the shoes
of
somebody else and that is life that is
sales that is every single day that is
empathy so say there's somebody at the
top of my organization and i want them
to mentor me or there's someone even
outside of my organization and i want
them to be my mentor the first thing i
do is i you know if it really helps you
actually pretend to be them write it
down on a piece of paper what their life
looks like let's just do steve barlet
you're asking steve butler to mentor you
so steve bartlett's day is he has an
unlimited things that people are asking
him to do he's getting thousands of dms
on social media they're all asking him
for stuff they're asking him for time to
go for a coffee to pick his brain to be
on his podcast to speak at their event
to do their show whatever it might be so
that's probably a really dumb place to
join the noise super saturated um
probably you know he's probably got a pa
defending those inboxes we're not gonna
[ __ ] try that that would be a stupid
thing to do let's find the least
saturated channel probably quite
honestly probably the post or probably
you know look at his channel hierarchy
probably twitter there's probably less
people there a channel where he's he's
um he's showing like he's responding
more but there's there's less people
competing there for his time so we might
go for the post or for twitter so let's
now pretend that you've got his
attention you've sent something in the
post you've written a tweet you've
written a twitter dm you've got his
attention once you have his attention
you need to convert it and to do that
you need to understand his psychological
incentives you have to know what i want
you have to solve a problem that i'm
looking for you have to appeal to my ego
you know steve oh my god i've listened
to every single podcast right
you have to understand the dynamics of
my life i know you have absolutely no
time
i am this person right and that's an
appeal you're making to maybe my empathy
to my care i am this person i'm 18 years
old one day i hope to you know build a
business like social chain because i've
listened to every single one of your
podcasts it would literally be my dream
if i could just stand in the background
of one episode one time i promise i
won't say a word it would literally
change my life right so what you've done
there is you've appreciated you're not
asking me for much you've hired you've
appreciated the fact that i'm busy by
saying i'm just gonna stand in the
background which means you're asking me
for zilch nothing and then you might end
up by saying and off the back of it
my friend works at this newspaper or
this magazine or has this blog i'm gonna
write a full transcript of my experience
this would be and then again you're
telling me that i'm gonna get something
in return right and then i look at it as
a proposition you've touched my ego
you've made me you know care through
empathy you've asked for nothing in
return of my time
and you've offered me a reward which is
you're going to put it somewhere you're
going to write it somewhere you're going
to help me by extending the reach for me
that's kind of the broad structure of a
perfect cold email asking for something
from someone that has no you know right
to give it to you is incredibly busy and
is being asked a lot the worst possible
case scenario let me give you the worst
possible case scenario hi steve
uh someone mentioned you the other day
which means that you don't know who i am
and you've not bothered to do your own
research um i want you to mentor me
uh let me know when to start and then
you've ended that with the let me know
when to start or whatever which is a
total presumption and sort of disrespect
and disregard of my time and my ability
to make that decision and then yeah and
also what you've done with that message
because it's so short and ill-conceived
you've proven to me that you're lazy and
that you're not creative and that you're
probably not someone that's going to
bring much value to my life and that's
genuinely how it works in my life i
swear to god i get dms from young people
they literally say
r letter r
space
there
any jobs go in
you've you've perfectly ruled yourself
out with that message of ever working
for me ever because you've told me that
you're both uncreative and lazy in only
a couple of words it's a remarkable
thing to achieve with such few amounts
of words you've told me you're lazy and
uncreative you will never work for
anything that i do in my entire life if
i ever see that message it shows that
you don't actually give a [ __ ] either
like you didn't even go on the website
to see if there were jobs going or you
didn't you know so
that's the that's the antithesis of
creativity attention to detail care and
ultimately success
and you know for some [ __ ] reason
people still do it
what are the three things that you would
look out for to know that you're on the
right path for success so the first
thing is definitely enjoyment if you're
not enjoying it especially an early
stage when it's going to be most
difficult then the chance of you being
successful is somewhere below one
percent
that is the single most important thing
are you enjoying it if the answer is no
then honestly you should quit
because it's only going to get more
difficult and the thing is we also tend
to shy away from things we're not
enjoying we tend to procrastinate away
from them because they create
psychological discomfort so if you're
not enjoying it you're probably also
going to do a pretty shitty job in it
it's hard to show up for something every
single day that you're not enjoying the
second thing is
at the very start of your business
there's not going to be a ton of
evidence that it's going well there's
probably not going to be a ton of
revenue probably not going to be a ton
of users
but there will be evidence of progress
evidence that you're getting better
evidence that you're making marginal
gains and for me and even with this
podcast i don't necessarily look for
results today or
more viewers or more downloads or more
revenue what i'm looking for is is this
thing getting one percent better week
over week because it only then takes 100
weeks for us to be 100 better and that
means we're moving in the right
direction and lastly i would say you're
looking for some kind of validation of
your hypothesis so in the context of
this podcast my validation would be am i
getting feedback from people and from
the data that they are enjoying the
format and the concept are they coming
back next week there might not be
thousands of people yet there might just
be 10 but are those 10 people inviting
one more and making my audience 11
people and there's always some evidence
even at the very very start of your
business especially if you've built it
in a lean way just to test your
hypothesis
that your hypothesis is being validated
that your product does have market fit
that people are enjoying the content
you're creating and that can act as a
tailwind to create it belief to create
enjoyment and motivation which will spur
you on to carry on going so to summarize
are you enjoying it are you making
marginal gains i.e progress and lastly
has your hypothesis
shown some evidence that it is correct
is there product market fit are people
enjoying what you're making are they
coming back again
hey steven and again um nice to uh hook
up with you um my question is um i've
been watching a lot of podcasts a lot of
motivation does help me a lot um i've
struggled over the years with anxiety
depression i've gone through a bit of
about a bit lately and just wondering
where you get your motivation from um
what makes you tick um and what makes
you get out of bed every day um
i'll get there i'm looking for other
avenues and uh you're inspiring me every
day and uh
just wanted to know really what
motivates you and drives you so it's
kind of ironic that within your question
lives the answer to your question you
said at the start of that that you
listen to this podcast it gives you
value and it's helped you
that's the reason why i get out of bed
in the morning purpose and so for me the
thing that drives me in any sort of
discipline or pursuit or ambition or
hobby that i have it's very very simple
and i've said this many times before it
has to be a worthwhile goal that's
challenging that i can pursue with
people i love and what you said
about how this podcast has helped you is
the reason it's worthwhile to me of
course it's challenging it takes tons of
my time the production takes a lot of
effort but it's a worthwhile challenge
so it's one worth pursuing and lastly i
get to do it with people that i actually
love and that's just a real fundamental
thing about human beings because you can
be pursuing a goal that means the world
to you a goal you love a goal that feels
incredibly worthwhile and meaningful but
if you're doing it with people that are
toxic in a toxic environment it then
becomes unworthwhile
it loses its enjoyment and the people
you're pursuing a goal with
are intrinsically attached to the
motivation to pursue it so the thing
that gets me out of bed and the the
prism in which i make my decisions
through in my life is is this a
worthwhile goal worthwhile is totally
subjective it's how it makes you feel
inside here is it a challenge because
the science says if something isn't
challenging you your motivation will
decline and are you doing it are you
pursuing it surrounded by people you
love
that'll make it a way more enjoyable way
more sustainable pursuit
thank you for all of your questions and
if you want to put a question to me the
details on how to do that are down below
in the description i hope you enjoyed
this new segment and i can't wait to
answer your question next week
[Music]